[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
publique que nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 20h30 ce 21 février 2020 et 1,22
par don est marquée par la prise
attendu de vladimir poutine voilà un
petit problème audio mais on règle ça je
disais ce 21 février 2022 est marquée
par la prise de parole attendu de
vladimir poutine un nouveau coup de
théâtre dans ce dossier ukrainien vous
savez qu emmanuel macron suit ce dossier
il a pris la main s'il a pris un certain
nombre d'initiatives et on va en parler
dans un instant avec yves thréard que
peut nous dire ce soir le maître du
kremlin quelles en seront les
conséquences
notre invité ce soir est olivier dussopt
bonsoir monsieur le ministre chargé des
comptes publics les comptes publics qui
n'ont jamais été autant dégrader ce sera
évidemment au centre de la campagne
électorale lorsque emmanuel macron aussi
sera candidat vous en parlerai tout à
l'heure avec brigitte boucher est en
train de mai qui vous interrogeons sur
les causes de cette dégradation est la
façon dont le candidat macro on peut
promettre de évidemment les restaurer et
qui a cramé la caisse vous aurez un
débat tout à l'heure avec deux
parlementaires qui vous demanderont
entre guillemets des comptes avoue le
ministre des comptes publics sur l'état
des finances nationales mais si vous le
voulez bien on va s'arrêter d'abord on
bouleverse un peu l'ordre de cette
émission à cause de cette actualité
internationale extrêmement tendu parce
qu'on a appris bonsoir yves très bon
choix les yeux bonsoir je lui dise vous
êtes le directeur adjoint du figaro vous
poserez les questions politiques tout à
l'heure dans un instant olivier du soft
mais d'abord posons les choses cette
actualité qui nous bouleverse ce soir
c'est donc la dîmière poutine qui va
faire une déclaration est ce qu'on en
connaît déjà la teneur pour l'essentiel
alors de source
croisé on va dire il pourrait annoncer
quelque chose qui est très important
parce que ça serait une rupture en fait
de la négociation ça reviendrait à ça
avec les européens notamment avec le
président macron puisque ce serait une
remise en question des accords de minsk
qui ont été signés en 2015 et c'est au
terme de ces accords l'intégrité du
territoire ukrainien doit être garantie
or là est bien le président poutine
pourrait annoncer
la l'autonomie mais poussé quasiment
l'indépendance de deux républiques déjà
très autonome de l'est de l'ukraine
la raison tout va ce c'est la république
autonome de lougansk et la république
autonome de donesk c'est à peu près au
total 10 % du territoire ukrainien alors
c'est indépendance reviendrait en fait à
une annexion de la part de moscou même
si le mot ne sera probablement pas
utilisé alex une annexion ça reviendrait
à faire ce que exactement vladimir
poutine a fait avec un crime et et
quelques années donc c'est une façon
aussi de provoquer le gouvernement de
kiev donc d'une présidence et d'un ski
parce que évidemment en faisant cela et
bien la balle est dans le camp d'une
certaine façon ukrainien et que vont
faire les ukrainiens il pourrait
éventuellement et bien par orgueil
fourbir les armes et à ce moment là
c'est eux qui seraient responsables
d'une certaine façon de d'un
affrontement armé doaks et c'est
toujours avec poutine toute manière des
coups de poker des provocations et il
est expert dans la mare la matière alors
on en est pas encore là on n'a pas de
bruits de bottes encore de représailles
de la part évidemment des ukrainiens
mais ce que vous nous dites c'est que la
reconnaissance de l'indépendance de ces
deux territoires qui sont dans le combat
si on peut dire qu'ils sont le dombass
dans les cellules dans l'est de
l'ukraine ça revient à une forme de
déclaration de guerre formelle au reste
enfin à l'ukraine déjà c'est une
atteinte à son intégrité territoriale
nécessairement bien sûr parce que ce
sont des républiques était déjà des
républiques autonomes comme vous avez
dans le reste du monde des régions qui
peuvent avoir une certaine autonomie par
rapport
au gouvernement central mais là ça
serait plus que ça ce serait carrément
du séparatisme c'est à dire que
l'autorité reconnue de ces deux
territoires qui serait reconnu par ces
deux territoires ne serait plus à kiev
mais elle serait évidemment à moscou et
on peut ne pas imaginer que vladimir
poutine ne soit pas derrière parce que
même si ce sont des républiques il faut
le dire peuplée de russophones c'est à
dire de gens qui parlent russe et de
gens qui pour la plupart d'entre eux
sont favorables à ce rattachement à
moscou encore une question et après
fondre et votre réaction cook est un
membre du gouvernement évidemment des
manuels macron ça met à bas tous les
efforts diplomatiques qui ont été
entrepris hier avant-hier et liem même
il ya des années c'est ça que ça veut
dire aussi effectivement alors je vous
le disais tout à l'heure ça remet en
question les accords de minsk qui ont
été petit qui ont été date de 2014 2015
2015 et ses accords de misc c'est un
désaccord qui
garantissent loto de l'as gabes à
l'intégrité du territoire d'abord et
deuxièmement que les choses puissent se
faire dans un dialogue entre les
allemands les français les russes et les
ukrainiens dans le cadre du format ce
qu'on appelait le format normandie
puisque tout ça a été imaginée lors de
l'anniversaire du débarquement en
normandie en 2015 avec le président
aulas alors olivier du soft emmanuel
macron on l'a appris aussi à quelques
minutes va ce soir dès ce soir
présider un conseil de défense nationale
pour évidemment réagir cette nouvelle
donne c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
en terme géopolitique d'abord il faut il
faire preuve de prudence nous nous
sommes dans un moment de grande tension
le chef de l'état est à la manoeuvre ils
multiplient les initiatives
diplomatiques est dans son rôle il a la
foi dans son rôle de président de la
république française dans son rôle de
président du conseil de l'union
européenne je suis très fier si on peut
l'exprimer ainsi d'avoir un président de
la république à la manoeuvre et qui
jusqu'au bout fait tout pour préserver
la paix qui met en oeuvre tous les
efforts possibles pour préserver la paix
et être médiateur mais la prudence parce
que dans une situation aussi tendue et
sur des sujets aussi graves évidemment
qu'une déclaration qu'une reconnaissance
de l'indépendance par moscou des deux
républiques évoquée serait une décision
lourde mais tant qu'elle n'est pas faite
il faut être prudent et surtout
lorsqu'on est membre du gouvernement et
que les prisons de la république est à
la manoeuvre il faut pas prendre le
risque de la confusion et je pense que
nous devons à la fois soutenir le
président la république nous le faisons
tous et ne devons pas entretenir
quelques forme de confusion que ce soit
quelqu'un précisons que ce soit dans le
sujet est sérieux il faudrait selon vous
on saura davantage ce soir parce que
l'europe évidemment va aussi réagir très
vite mais en même temps qu'on doit
continuer la négociation
elle est toujours compatible avec y
compris la guerre il faut commencer à
brandir et va mettre en oeuvre des
sanctions européennes si vladimir
poutine évidemment confirmait cet
indépendant d'abord vous avez raison de
parler au conditionnel c'est aussi une
raison de la prudence et je crois que
tous les chefs d'état européens ont dit
leur volonté de réagir mais là aussi ne
précipitons pas les choses je suis en
charge du budget des comptes publics et
non pas de la diplomatie ni la défense
et m s'invite à cette prudence quand je
le répète je pense que dans des
circonstances comme celles ci la
confusion ou l'imprécision l'imprudence
ne sont pas ni acceptable ni ni
recommandé l'impossible vous avez raison
il faut du sang-froid dans ces cas là et
on attend d'avoir
exposition en prison dit république qui
ne manquent pas et qui loue des minutes
et on vous donnera donc des précisions
dès que possible et frère des
conséquences politiques bien sûr alors
des conséquences la première des
conséquences politiques évidemment c'est
qu'on attendait cette semaine la
déclaration de candidature du président
de la république on savait déjà qu'elle
pourrait être reportée à la semaine
suivante
donc le président de la république va se
déclarer au dernier moment il a jusqu'au
4 mars puisque c'est le 4 mars que
commence à être comptabilisés par le
conseil constitutionnel
les parrainages nécessaires à
l'officialisation d'une candidature
est-ce que c'est pas un handicap
finalement pour le président de la
république de se déclarer auscitains je
ne crois pas et pour deux raisons
d'abord il est président de la
république nous l'avons toujours dit il
travaillera jusqu'à la dernière minute
et j'espère bien évidemment qui
travaillera dès la première minute d'un
second quart d'heure dernier quart
d'heure et je vais jusqu'à la dernière
minute et j'espère même les premières
minutes du second quinquennat et donc
l'actualité montre qu'il a raison de
prendre le temps avant d'entrer en
campagne et de se concentrer sur les
sujets les plus essentiels il a d'autant
plus raison qu'il peut compter sur une
majorité qui est prête qui est prêt de
kate unis et il peut compter sur des
équipes de campagne qui sont d'ores et
déjà mobilisés et donc il n'ya pas de
handicap
donc le président de la république se
déclara quand il le souhaitera il le
fera sur la base de ce qu'il a fait
pendant ce quinquennat et sur le projet
qu'il présentera aux français qu'il ya
une deuxième raison c'est que en réalité
présente la république depuis 2007 les
mène une sorte de campagne permanente
par le ton qu'il prend pour écouter par
le temps qu'il prend pour se déplacer
par les risques' qu'il a pris en menant
des réformes qui parfois été difficile
et qui ont été menées à bien et donc
nous sommes dans une période de campagne
certes mais il est aussi les priorités
et l'actualité montre que celles ci sont
évidemment première alors vous vous êtes
présumé incarner l'ailé gauche de la
majorité présidentielle et a même à
l'intérieur du gouvernement avec jean
yves le drian alors que joe rospars lit
avec d'autres regardent plutôt l'allèle
droite on va dire est ce que vous vous
attendez ce que vous travaillez à ce que
des anciens leaders socialistes on a vu
ce week-end et bien rallye la majorité
on a vu madame touraine on a vu madame
guigou ou si l'ancien monsieur sans en
sortant des cadres de ce qu'était le ps
il est quelques secondes quelqu'un en
maintenant le maire de dunkerque y ai
dit qu'ils n'avaient pas pris position
en 2017 et qu'au vu du bilan et
considère qu'il n'y a pas photo je
reprendrai une expression soutenir
emmanuel macron et j'ai la chance de
présider une formation politique
territoire de progrès qui enregistre
adhésion d'élus locaux de merde à jack
la promesse de et droite et gauche comme
il continuera claude guichon appelle le
dépassement le déplacement nécessite du
rassemblement nous étions tout à l'heure
toutes les forces de la majorité réunis
justement pour travailler pour à la fois
mobilisé nos relais ainsi pour
travailler pour échanger avec l'ensemble
des partis qui forment la maison commune
c'est là la force des manuels macron
c'est sa force d'avoir su rassembler
autour d'un projet autour de sa personne
aussi pour que des hommes et des femmes
venus d'horizons différents puis se
travailler ensemble alors si juste une
petite question c'est mon père ma tête
un propos de socialiste rallié ségolène
royal qui soutient jean luc mélenchon
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire on
rappelle que vous êtes socialiste à
l'origine oui vous avez soutenu cette
candidate qui a été calme oui il ya
quinze ans maintenant mais d'abord ce
son choix très franchement c'est son
choix j'ai du mal à le comprendre mais
c'est son choix et ce n'est pas à moi de
le commenter tout simplement de trouver
est ce qu'on voudrait qu'il ya une
cohérence pouvait aussi voir les choses
de façon plus extérieur politique et une
cohérence entre ce qu'elle apportait en
tant que candidate socialiste au second
tour et ce qu'est enfin les enfants nuit
spontanément je ne la vois pas mais
celle de répondre à la question c'est
aussi l'illustration une des
illustrations du fait que cette famille
socialiste ce parti sns parti société
telle qu'on l'a connue n'existe plus et
qui finalement n'est plus rien qui lie
qui que ce soit qui cimente qui que ce
soit ségolène royal a fait un choix en
faveur jean luc mélenchon c'est le sien
je n'ai ni à le critiquer ni à le blâmer
c'est son choix tout simplement alors
dans le même ordre d'idées qui ce qui
est un peu sur quoi pu surprendre cette
ce week-end david lisnard le maire de
cannes qui est aussi qu'ils aient l'air
il faut le dire les républicains carême
était à un moment pressenti pour être
candidat à la présidence de la
république a décidé d'apporter sa
signature son parrainage à jean luc
mélenchon c'est une première dans la
république je crois savoir de façon
aussi manifestes et revendiquée est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
connais beaucoup de maires dans des
communes de petite taille elles donnent
leur parrainage à des candidats dont on
parle ne vaut pas soutirer
des parrainages qui sont donnés à
nathalie arthaud par exemple philippe
poutou sans partage est nécessairement
leurs idées mais en considérant qu'il
faut que le débat vif est-ce qu'il faut
changer les airs la rue main je t'ai
tout le monde s'interroge sur le
changement de règle à loeb d'une la
veille d'une présidentielle sans jamais
se poser la question cinq ans avant la
règle est posée aujourd'hui elle existe
n'est pas nouvelle il ya quarante mille
élus qui peuvent signer mais il faut 500
signatures 500 présentations pour être
candidat shaq fu chaque élection
présidentielle on se pose la question de
la règle du jeu je pense que désormais
déposer et qu'on ne va pas la changer en
cours de route françois perrault a pris
une initiative qui est de rassembler de
recenser si je puis dire
des parrain des parrains potentiels qui
seraient prêts parce qu'il considère que
parrainage ne vaut pas soutien à
permettre ce qu'elle fit candidats
principaux de plusieurs candidats
principaux de pouvoir participer à cette
élection présidentielle c'est une
démarche qui est intéressante parce que
ce serait effectivement embêtant
dommageable que des candidats qu'ils
obtiennent dans les études d'opinion
dans les indes et les intentions de vote
des scores non négligeable ne puisse pas
participer jusqu'au bout des bas mais il
ya une règle et je ne me sens pas la
légitimité de demander à tel ou tel élu
de passe et autres ses convictions pour
donner un parrainage même si comme vous
l'avez dit parrainage ne vaut pas
soutient alors ça ça fait partie des
institutions de la république est ce
qu'il faut cette réforme des
institutions qui a été mille fois
promise et notamment valu au président
de la république sortant est-ce qu'il
faut s'y atteler pour certains ça doit
être un dossier qui doit être traité en
début de quinquennat mais je pense que
la priorité ça reste les questions
économiques et sociales d'accord c'est
là dessus que va se jouer la campagne et
je pense que les questions économiques
et sociales qui sont d'éducation les
questions d'égalité des chances trim en
tout cas je le crois dans l'opinion
publique sur les questions
institutionnelles d'accord et vous
avez-vous pensé que dans l'arsenal des
propositions qui qui sont en préparation
pour la campagne emmanuel macron c'est
celle ci ce sont ces thèmes là qui vont
émerger d'abord il va falloir attendre
que vous venez de me confier et vous
vous avez vous avez produit des notes
séoul souhaitait en tout cas oui mais
les deux questions c'est rarement un
sujet par exemple de campagne
présidentielle que nous avons vécu un
quinquennat nous nous arrivons à la fin
d'un quinquennat qui a été marquée par
plusieurs crises la crise des gis les
jeunes avec des populations et des
territoires parfois les deux qui avaient
le sentiment d'une relégation d'un
déclassement et finalement d'une forme
d'impasse sociale au sens de
l'émancipation et de la capacité à
lutter conte les déterminismes sociaux
on a aussi vécu un confinement au delà
même de la crise sanitaire et ses
conséquences dramatiques un confinement
avec des risques et est d'ailleurs c'est
ce que nous suce contre quoi nous avons
lutté systématiquement et dans des
risques de déscolarisation avec des
enfants qui n'ont pas tous la chance
d'avoir des parents capacité d'assurer
sa continuité pédagogique je pense que
ça vient souligner un des enjeux de la
campagne des manuels macron fin 2016
début 2017 qui reste totalement
d'actualité c'est le refus l'assignation
à résidence
c'est la volonté d'émancipation
collective et individuelle c'est la
volonté de donner aux uns et aux autres
la maîtrise de leur destin cette
question de l'égalité des chances parce
que c'est de cela dont on aime ça passe
nécessairement par l'éducation et au
delà des que d'éducation par la
formation mais ça passe d'abord par
l'éducation parce que c'est là qu'on
peut aussi lutter contre les racines de
l'inégalité
si même s'il n'est pas élu d'ailleurs le
président de la république sortant s'il
n'est pas réélu est ce que vous serez
candidat ou religieux ne sais pas encore
je ne sais pas encore je sens encore en
réflexion avec les amis qui m'entourent
et qui m'accompagne en ardèche et si il
est élu réélu est ce que vous êtes
candidat à continuer votre travail à
l'hystérie la constitution n'ont pas
l'instant dit que le gouvernement de la
république est nommé par le président la
république sur proposition du premier
ministre oui faut qu'il y ait un
président il faut qu'ils aient un
premier ministre ça fait partie des
fonctions et des responsabilités que
j'exerce avec une fierté et un honneur
qui est ingérable vous voulez mais cela
fait partie des fonctions qui ne se
demande pas et qu'il se refuse pas alors
vous avez eu deux premiers ministres
deux premiers ministres étaient issus
des rangs de la droite est ce que cette
fois pour faire est de droite et de
gauche eh bien pourquoi pas deuxième
quinquennat avec dédé premier ministre
qui serait plutôt issus de la gauche
chaque choses dans l'ordre il a d'abord
une élection présidentielle ensuite le
président de république
pardon mais nous sommes sur des
questions de deux d'anticipation pour ne
pas dire de politique fiction sur les
questions de casting sur des questions
de choix qui relève d'un homme le
président de la république je peux me
prêter à toutes les
idées possibles et à toutes les rivières
les allégations ce n'est pas le terme le
mieux choisi mais ça n'est pas tout à
fait mon style
alors est ce qu a remis en question et
dernière question
est ce que vous pensez que la politique
étrangère peut être un handicap si
jamais le président de la république qui
chaud le dossier ukrainien jusqu'à
présent a plutôt été je dirais porté par
un vent favorable
là les déclarations qu'on attend de
vladimir poutine pourrait remettre en
question et bien ce qu'il a dit ce qu'il
a fait jusqu'à présent est ce que ça
pourrait être un handicap du tout je ne
crois pas que hausse qui aurait pu être
un handicap c'est qu'ils ne fassent rien
et je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
forme de fierté c'est évidemment soutien
aux initiatives qui sont prises le
président la république met tout en
oeuvre le dossier est difficile la
situation est tendue les réactions sont
parfois imprévisibles et ce dossier
difficile non pas depuis cette année
mais les destine depuis des années et
des années on a entendu échec au sahel
donc s'il ya échec non en europe de
l'est je ne crois pas que les choses se
personnalise ainsi et je pense que le
président de la république aurait été
critiqué s'il n'avait rien fait et
peut-être qu'ils auraient été écrites
des critiques et a juste droit il fait
tout
tout ce qu'il peut pour éviter ce
conflit et pour jouer le rôle de
médiateur c'est ce qu'on attend de lui
merci beaucoup
je le souhaite et je ferai tout pour
cela oui mais ça j'imagine que vous
n'avez pas faire le contraire mais je
pose la question parce qu'il peut y
avoir de l'optimisme
je pense qu'une élection n'est jamais
gagnée donc j'ai confiance nous avons un
bon bilan devant une bonne équipe nous
ont un bon président et donc ça c'est
une raison d'être confiants par contre
l'optimisme ça n'est pas une façon de
faire campagne la meilleure façon de
faire campagne c'est la mobilisation
c'est un projet et c'est la défense d'un
candidat encore une question de parler
des parrainages ou on va plutôt parler
des parrainages tout à l'heure mais déjà
un mot
j'ai entendu fabien roussel le candidat
communiste dire ce matin que si eric
zemmour et jean luc mélenchon n'avait
pas leur signature ce serait pas si mal
pour la démocratie c'est pas si mal
qu'ils ne puissent pas les avoir et donc
soit empêché d'être candidat à la
présidence je peux partager non jeu je
pense qu'on ne gagne jamais empêché le
débat est donc on ne gagne pas empêché
le débat est donc vous souhaiter qu'ils
aient leur signale sans revenir sur ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur le fait
que parrainage nouveau pas soutient sans
revenir sur le fait que je me sens pas
la légitimité de demander un élu de
passer outre ses convictions s'ils ne le
souhaitent pas je pense que le débat
gagnerait parce que les principaux
candidats puissent y participer c'est
diriger boucher est en train de mai nous
ont rejoint respectivement représentant
lcp et public sénat mesdames c'est tabou
il sort olivier dussopt qu on va parler
de la cour des comptes qui a dressé la
semaine dernière un constat assez sévère
de l'état de nos finances publiques avec
une dette à 113 5 % du pib la france est
une des pires élèves de la zone euro et
pour son président pierre moscovici on
ne peut pas tout mettre sur le compte du
coc vide est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat j'ai aussi lu dans le
même rapport que la cour des comptes
s'est félicité de la manière dont nous
avons répondu à la crise des outils qui
ont été mises en place pour aider
l'économie à traverser ce cap
extrêmement difficile et pour
accompagner les français mais moi je
vous parle on d'avant la crise qu vide
au jeu le rapport vous citez n'est pas
sûr avant les risques aux ide il est sur
la période du coville est est ce que
vous citez c'est le rapport annuel 2022
qui porte sur les exercices 2020 et 2021
nous sommes en pleine crise qu vide et
il se trouve que j'ai lu page par page
alors quand on regarde 2018 2,3 pour son
déficit 2010 9 3% donc ça augmente quand
même énormément vous oubliez un point je
l'avais dit d'ailleurs sur un nouveau
plateau en 2009 c'est la transformation
du crédit impôt compétitivité en
allègements de charge s'est traduit par
un réhaussement du déficit conjoncturel
ponctuel de 0,9 point puisque en 2019
nous avions rembourser le crédit d'impôt
type de l'année 2018 et accorder les
allégements de charges et donc le
déficit hors cet effet one shot pardon
pour l'anglicisme n'était pas de devenir
de trois comme vous dites mais de 2,1 il
était dans la trajectoire c'était la
troisième année consécutive que la
france tenait cet objectif de 3% nous
avions maîtriser la dette est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé à la suite de la crise
qu vide nous avons dépensé beaucoup
d'argent
monde d'ailleurs ne reconnais que nous
avons bien fait de le faire et elin
s'est dit que si nous n'avions pas
dépenser cet argent nous ne serions pas
à centrer ce point de déficit et de
dette publique par dont nous serions
plutôt à 130 à 135 vous veillez donc à
bien gérer les finances publiques on est
contents non je dis que nous sommes le
premier gouvernement avoir tenu des
engagements la barre des 3% nous sommes
le gouvernement qui a accompagné
l'économie plutôt efficacement chacun
chacun le constater et le pense je crois
avec une reprise économique est très
forte avec une dette qui a certes
augmenté il est hors de question de dire
que l aide de la zone euro quand même
donc parce que tout le monde a eu locaux
vides enfin tout le monde a eu de quoi
qu'il en coûte qui relève de la zone
euro nous avons une dette qui a augmenté
de 13 points c'est moins que la plupart
des pays européens donc il faut le
regarder aussi de très près et nous
avons une croissance qui est la
meilleure de la zone euro avec un taux
de chômage qui a baissé et qui est au
plus bas depuis 2008 donc la réponse que
nous avons apporté une réponse efficace
aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître qu'il ya
dégradation des finances publiques le
passage de 99,99 et demi à 113 6 % de
dette publique ce n'est pas rien donc il
faut aussi reconnaître que le déficit
s'est creusé il était à 9 en 2020 nous
l'avons ramené à 7 en 2021 nous le
ramèneront à 5 en 2022 et nous
ramènerons progressivement vers les 3 %
mettons les rosaces ivement c'est tout
l'enjeu est là tant des comptes est
quand même inquiète pour l'avenir elle
estime que votre trajectoire pour
atteindre la barre des 3% en 2027 n'est
pas réaliste dixit incertain qu'est ce
que vous lui avec dire certains nous
paraît irréaliste il faut là aussi très
précis sur les termes et j'engage chacun
lire le rapport page après page pour
revenir à 3% en 2027 il faut que la
dépense publique hors inflation évolué
de 0 8 % maximum par an c'est ce que
nous avons fait entrer en 2007 2018 et
2013 alors pouvait traduire par ce que
pour tous ceux qui ne
pensent public en france et vous avez
aussi une inflation et nous nous
intéressons à l'augmentation de la
dépense publique en neutralisant l'effet
de l'inflation pour avoir des choses qui
soit comparable les unes avec les autres
et donc si ce total de la dépense
publique augmente de 0,8 pour cent
maximum par an c'est autour d'une grosse
dizaine de milliards d'euros par an
alors nous tenons à ce que toi est-ce
que vous pouvez tenir cette promesse
tout toujours en refusant d'augmenter
les impôts oui et nous avons démontré
puisque au cours de ce quinquennat nous
avons baissé les impôts de 50 milliards
d'euros alors même que nous avons réduit
le rythme de la dépense publique et vous
confirmer que ça sera une promesse d'
emmanuel macron candidats de toujours
revenir la tige et de l'occasion de dire
tout à l'heure à elisabeth martichoux
que les promesses des candidats emmanuel
macron ses engagements plus tôt c'est
lui qui les prendra au moment où il
présentera son projet par contre ce que
je peux vous garantir c'est que nous
sommes convaincus avec lui qu'on ne sort
pas de la crise ne sont pas d'une crise
en augmentant les impôts nous sortons
d'une crise en rendant du prix d'achat
aux français et en rendant de la
compétitivité aux entreprises ce que
nous avons fait au cours des ans sort
d'une crise dans les b sens c'est ce que
nous avons fait
si nous avons la possibilité de le faire
ce serait une bonne nouvelle pour les
français comme pour les entreprises mes
impôts l'impôt sur le revenu les impôts
de production les caviars pendant ce
quinquennat nous avons supprimé la taxe
d'habitation c'est 723 euros par foyer
nous avons baisser l'impôt sur le revenu
de 5 milliards en concentrant les effets
de la baisse sur la première et la
deuxième tranche et nous avons baissé
les impôts des entreprises sur les 50
milliards d'euros c'est moitié pour les
entreprises moitié pour les ménages qui
nous avons au cours de ce quinquennat
pardon parce que je tiens à le souligner
nous avons effacé les deux vague
d'augmentations d'impôts qui avait été
connue depuis 2010 la première vague
c'est dans le budget pour 2012 madame
pécresse était muni du budget elle a
présenté un budget avec 15 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts notamment le
gène du barème de l'impôt sur le revenu
mais pas seulement et nous avons aussi
effacé l'augmentation des impôts de fin
2013 début 2014
au début du quinquennat de françois
hollande et nous revenons un taux de
prélèvements obligatoires qui est celui
de 2010 la direction table sur une
proposition de marine le pen qui elle
propose de ne pas payer d'impôts avant
30 ans qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
elle ne sait pas le financer elle ne
sait pas le financer elle considère que
plutôt que de revaloriser les métiers de
revaloriser les débuts de carrière comme
nous l'avons fait dans l'enseignement il
faudrait un grand du pouvoir d'achat par
une baisse d'impôt qu'elle ne sait pas
financer qui représente plusieurs
milliards d'euros la problème c'est le
financement qu'est ce que vous pensez du
principe je pense que quand on vit dans
une société quand on bénéficie de
service public comme les services
publics français quand on a pu mesurer
l'importance du service public et des
politiques publiques au monde la crise
il est important de contribuer à juste
proportion est à due proportion de ses
moyens et je ne pense pas que ce soit un
bon signal que de dire qu'en fonction de
l'âge des 1 ou 2 autre il y aurait des
exonérations fiscales particulières
qu'est ce que vous pensez sinon de la
proposition de règle d'or budgétaire et
fiscale de valérie pécresse elle
n'existe pas pourquoi n'existait pas
d'abord parce qu'il faudrait une réforme
constitutionnelle et ça lui est
impossible ça n'est pas impossible mais
ça veut dire qu'en cas de crise comme
celle que nous avons connue de l'année
dernière et l'année d'avant l'état
aurait les mains liées ne pourrait pas
apporter la réponse que nous avons
apportées
mais sur les lieux principe sur l'idée
en fait on voit bien que dans les
collectivités locales on n'a pas le
droit de faire un budget en déficit là
par exemple ouais et ce serait pas une
bonne chose qu'on puisse se faire pour
les terres on vote depuis des dizaines
d'années des députés en déficit depuis
avant ma naissance effectivement à la
mémé d'abord les collectivités ou les
collectivités ont une obligation
malheureusement entre page et
je suis né en 1918 dans ce cas là mais
quelques quelques mois après le dernier
budget équilibré à l'écran
des formations
revenir à plus de sérieux pardon les
collectivités sans astreinte à un
équilibre sur leur section de
fonctionnement et elles peuvent financer
l'investissement par de l'emprunt donc
de la dette est une forme si on veut
dire de déséquilibre je pense qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent en matière de
finances publiques et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je défends cette
trajectoire de retour progressif dans
les 3 % et progressivement vers
l'équilibré progressive pour ne pas
étouffer la croissance est majeur dans
la stratégie qui est la nôtre et et
progressive parce que nous devons être
attentifs à ce que la qu'il est la
nature de la dépense dans les textes qui
ont été récemment voté une proposition
de loi parlementaire
porté par le rapporteur général ici et
laurent saint martin l'assemblée
nationale et par eric woerth comme
président de la commission a revu ce
qu'on appelle les règles organiques qui
entoure la gestion des finances
publiques et notamment prévoit le de
mieux différencier s'il relève des
investissements et ce qui relève du
fonctionnement va pas en très bonne
équipe pour cette trajectoire des
finances publiques et la respecte et il
faudrait économiser 9 milliards d'euros
par an nous dit la cour des comptes
c'est 9 milliards vous voulez trouver où
c'est une économie en tendance
aujourd'hui vous avez une dépense
publique pardon parce que je vais pour
le coup retourner à des choses fait
technique mais vous avez une dépense
publique qui évolue naturellement
4e dépenses publiques évolué de manière
structurelle à ce qu'il y a de
revalorisation parce qu'il ya des
indices parce qu'il ya des tendances et
donc si vous arrivez à dégager 9
milliards d'euros ne s'agit pas de
baisser les dépenses actuelles de 9
milliards d'euros mais de limiter les
dépenses 9 milliards en dessous de ce
qu'elle devrait être si vous ne prenez
aucune mesure et aucune forme de
régulation c'est vraiment de l'économie
en tendance je répète c'est ce que nous
avons fait entre 2017 et hélas le début
du coc vie donc fin 2019 début 2000 20
dans une période qui n'est pas une
période aussi tu es donc ce que vous
dites c'est qu'il ya pas besoin
finalement de grandes réformes comme
celle des retraites assurance chômage il
permettrait l'un d'eux devrait durement
même déficit en forme d'assurance
chômage de fait il ya des réformes
structurelles elle est finie la
réfondation chauvel et n'irait pas plus
loin il est en cours de mise en oeuvre
il faut aller au bout de sa mise en
oeuvre il ya des réformes structurelles
qu'il faut aborder il faut repenser les
politiques publiques il faut s'assurer
que l'argent dépensé et utile s'appelle
la revue des dépenses publiques mais les
retraites c'est indispensable nous a
amenés par les retraites ça devait être
c'est une réforme indispensable pour
deux raisons la première c'est qu'il
faut mettre plus de justice dans ce
système arrêtez de sanctionner des
polypensionnés faire en sorte que le
changement d'employeur parfois aussi la
précarité ne soit pas d élément de
sanction du calcul de la retraite et
puis faut aussi garantir les qu'il
finance et d'un système qui avant la
crise ne l'était pas mais qui les
passagers dire qu'il aura peut-être
aller plus loin que les 64 ans je ne
sais pas si j'aurai plus loin que ses 64
ans fera partie des objets de débats de
la campagne et du des millions parmi ces
comprimés il faut il oui il faut avoir
une réforme qui associe à la fois la
justice et une capacité contributive
plus forte ceci est la justice et ne pas
sanctionner la précarité c'est mieux
prendre en compte la pénibilité c'est
tenir compte des carrières tenir compte
des parcours c'est permettre aussi
peut-être d'avoir des trajectoires plus
individuel avec
volume de travail à un nombre d'heures
travaillées par semaine qui pourrait
varier tout au long de la vie ça veut
dire quoi ça ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous pouvez avoir 30 ans 40 ans vous
plaire dans votre métier je sais que ce
n'est pas le cas de tout le monde c'est
malheureusement une réalité et avoir la
possibilité l envie de travailler assez
fortement d'avoir des jours sur votre
compte épargne temps et pouvoir les
mobiliser ensuite un autre moment de
votre carrière en garantissant que ce
les droits que vous avez acquis leçon
quel que soit l'employeur n'est pas une
usine à gaza non je ne crois pas ce sont
des choses qui peuvent exister qui
peuvent être travaillés dire qu'on
aurait un compte permanents sur lequel
on aura une possibilité de prendre des
congés payés c'est vous savez la cfdt a
apporté une proposition de protection
professionnels universelle avec la
garantie que les droits vous avez acquis
c'est peut-être des droits à congés de
vraies informations vous suivre pendant
toute votre carrière je trouve ça
intéressant parce que c'est une position
qui peut prospérer pendant la campagne
nous verrons je vois bien ce que voulait
dire nous verrons ce qui se passe dans
les prochaines semaines en tout cas
comment vous appelez ça avec des droits
va y est je trouve que je pense
apparaîtrait dans le plagiat mais je
trouve que lorsque la cfdt parle de
protection professionnels universel
c'est un concept qui est intéressant et
avec mes amis de territoire de progrès
nous nous y travaillons et nous nous
faisons cela
je pense que ça c'est une réforme de
protection énorme solidarité
donc vous annoncez certainement qu'il va
falloir avoir une réforme des retraites
à ce qu'il faut aussi travailler plus
pour vous et revenir sur les 35 heures
emmanuel macron à parler de la france
comme d'un pays qui travaillent moins
que les autres cet automne je crois que
les dérogations qui existaient l'arrêt
des 35 heures les possibilités de
négocier sont suffisantes et permettent
il faut pas aller plus loin le dialogue
social aux entreprises aux personnes qui
le souhaitent de travailler plus je
pense que l' équilibre qui a été trouvé
ta est un bon équilibre vous ne bougez
pas et à ce sujet là nous avons pris une
bonne décision au début du quinquennat
qui est venu corriger une erreur que
nous avons commise et jeudi nous à
dessein puisque je participais à la
majorité précédente à l'assemblée
nationale cette erreur a été de rufisque
alizés les heures supplémentaires je
pense que rétrospectivement c'était une
erreur et lourde erreur qui a peut être
marqué d'ailleurs une forme de divorce
entre ce qu'on appelait la gauche de
gouvernement et une partie des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes parce
que cette défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires bénéficie avant tout à
des employés des ouvriers des
techniciens de pme tpe est plutôt à des
gens avec un salaire
modestes ou moyens j'ai des exemples qui
me viennent pas par dizaines on parle de
on parlait de 250 300 euros pour des
coupes qui naît entre 3000 et 3500 euros
par mois c'est une erreur nous l'avons
corrigée et sait aussi ce type de mesure
qui permet d'aboutir à l' équilibre que
j'évoquais on a parlé de réduction de la
dépense publique est ce qu'il faut pour
vous réduire le nombre de fonctionnaires
valérie pécresse par exemple parle de la
baisse de 150 mille fonctionnaires c'est
la seule à a prôné cette rigueur vous
expliquer qu'elle nous dise lesquels
qu'elle nous dise lesquels elle dit
partout partout mais ça ne veut pas
redon mais par tous et nul part et elle
ne documente pas le par l'administration
administrante un concept que celle elle
semble le connaître visiblement et pour
vous avons justement j'y viens nous
avons débuté ce quinquennat avec un
objectif qui était une réduction de 50
milles qui vole en temps plein par non
remplacement de tous les départs à la
retraite d'une partie des départs leur
retraite et on y prête cet objectif n'a
pas été tenues pourquoi il n'a pas été
tenue parce que des besoins ont été
identifiées des besoins du christ c'est
une évidence même si
nous avons commencé à le faire mais
aujourd'hui nous finissons l équilibre
nous avons aussi identifié les besoins
par exemple temps à l'occasion du grand
débat national il est mis l'accent sur
la nécessité d'accentuer la formation
professionnelle et les formations
qualifiantes après le bac je pense
notamment au bts quand qu'on met en
place un plan bts avec presque un
millier de recrutements ça répond à un
besoin et c'est utile donc en matière et
dans le domaine de la fonction publique
je pense que le plus sage c'est
de garantir que nous ayons des services
publics de qualité donc il n'y a plus
d'objectifs de réduction de continuer l
air sur le prochain quinquennat
continuer à les moderniser garantir des
services publics de qualité c'est
important quand il y allait moderniser
quand la modernisation permet de
réaliser des économies d'échelle permet
de d'être plus productifs plus efficace
et permet de diminuer le nombre de
personnes affectées à cet âge tant mieux
parce que ça représente une économie
quand il ya des priorités qui nécessite
de créer des postes il faut le faire
aussi je le répète pardon parce qu'on
est dans une période un peu particulière
mais vous m'interrogez pour la troisième
ou la quatrième fois en me disant est ce
que ça sera une promesse du prochain
quinquennat soyez juste un peu patient
de pardon mais le président d'areva mais
non de les attendre je vois ça alors que
nous nous sommes parfaitement serein
nous avons un président qui préside et
nous savons et j'espère évidemment que à
mons prison sera un candidat avec un bon
projet mais cette sérénité fait qu'on
n'a pas l'impatience envoûte et moisé ce
mérite
oui cette dernière
le pouvoir d'achat il s'est amélioré sur
le quinquennat et pourtant les français
ne le ressentent pas comme tel comment
vous l'expliquez est ce qui vous fait
faire plus du coup pour aujourd'hui la
hausse des prix les nerfs vous avez
raison de souligner qui s'est améliorée
largement amélioré on aura sûrement
l'occasion d'y revenir mais c'est une
augmentation forte qui puisse 2,2 pour
cent par an et c'est deux fois plus vite
que la moyenne des dix dernières années
est-ce que ses doigts amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat se ressent vous avez
aussi répondu très souvent dans les
études d'opinion ce qui ressort c'est
que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ressenti
une des explications que je vois cet
état de fait qui ne concerne pas que ce
gouvernement en tout cas pas pour la
première fois tous les gouvernements
précédents ont été confrontés à cette
difficulté de faire mesurer des rendre
sensible est tangible les mesures en
matière pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi lié
à d'autres phénomènes et pas seulement
la question des revenus disponibles
c'est lié à des questions de dépenses
contraintes et il ya une très bonne
étude de france raté gicle date d'il ya
quelques semaines qui montre que la part
des dépenses contraintes dans le budget
des ménages est de plus en plus
importante qu'elle augmente depuis
maintenant plus de 20 ans et qu'elle est
évidemment celle vous créditeront peuple
est dans le pré dont vous pouvoir
d'achat chez les ménages les moins
favorisés chez les ménages les plus
favorisés c'est une question de coûts
fixes et dans ses dépenses contraintes
il ya des questions d'assurance et des
questions de logement et puis je pense
qu'il faut aussi ajouter sur les
énergies comment vous n'aimez pas le cas
des as aperçu à l'isf actions s'y
ajouter des dépenses contraintes de la
dernière question est-ce que socialement
je dis souvent mais quand j'étais
adolescent mes parents avaient une ligne
de téléphone fixe et samedi pour toute
la maison aujourd'hui quand vous êtes en
couple et que vous avez trois enfants
adolescents c'est difficile de ne pas
voir
ce que je dis c'est que nous avons fait
un certain nombre d'efforts des efforts
même important nous avons augmenté la
prime d'activité au niveau du smic nous
avons baissé les cotisations nous avons
je répète défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires a augmenté les minima
sociaux qu'ils sont là lancé bon on
arrive l'année et même vieillesse nous
luttons contre l'augmentation des prix
l'énergie et nous essayons de faire en
sorte que les revenus du travail paye
systématiquement mais je ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui considèrent que parce
que nous prenons de bonne mesure et je
pense qu'elles sont bonnes je pense
qu'elle augmente le pouvoir d'achat
je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
balaient d'une main le sentiment de
français qui nous disent que ça devient
difficile dans les dépenses contraintes
sont plus en plus sentir et que les
consciences attaqués à des questions de
primes est question de formation de prix
et des questions de logement où nous
avons voté pardon je prends juste un
exemple la semaine passée le parlement a
voté à l'unanimité
la forme de l'assurance emprunteur
l'assurance emprunteur c'est l'assurance
que vous payez quand vous faites en
emprunts immobiliers en autorisant les
particuliers en changer à tout moment et
pas seulement aux douze mois d'échéances
c'est une mesure qui va générer des
économies par une meilleure concurrence
en utilisation antonella nous estimons
que c'est plusieurs centaines d'euros
par an donc pas de hausse de salaire et
papa dead davantage sur les carreaux
brisés vous le savez nous sommes à 15
milliards dead sur les qui sont des
nageurs ans pas plus 15 milliards
d'euros et pour ce qui concerne les
salaires vous savez aussi combien ma
collègue elisabeth bornes travail avec
les différentes branches procès pour
professionnels pour les inciter à orvin
la grille merci beaucoup brigitte et âme
et ont rejoint tout de suite vincent
bonsoir vincent émission un peu
bouleversé ce soir on vous rejoindra
qu'une fois mais ce sera la bonne vous
êtes en direct du figaro live vincent
une question à olivier du soft oui
bonsoir olivier dussopt bonsoir
elizabeth il ya une grande émotion qui a
été suscitée par un accident qui a eu
lieu ce week-end dans le cantal une
randonneuse de 25 ans tuée lors d'un
accident de chasse depuis
beaucoup demandent à durcissement des
conditions d'octroi notamment des permis
de chasse certains vont jusqu'à demander
la suspension de la chasse le week-end
et pendant les vacances scolaires quel
est votre point de vue olivier dussopt
d'abord un point de vue de grande
tristesse pour la victime et sa famille
c'est un drame absolu et c'est une vie
fauchée c'est aussi la volonté ou en
tout cas le la nécessité à mes yeux de
ne jamais réagir à chaud sur tel drame
je pense que l'observation le respect
des règles fixées pour la pratique de la
chasse sont une nécessité absolue je
sais aussi les efforts de formation que
font beaucoup de fédérations
départementales de chasseurs je ne sais
pas si et je ne sais pas dire si
l'interdiction ou la suspension de là
chastel ou tel jour serait de nature à
totalement et éviter les risques et donc
je pense qu'il faut avant tout miser sur
la question de la formation et quant à
la question de l'octroi des permis que
ce soit un système extrêmement vigilant
extrêmement attentifs ça me paraît
nécessaire
mais je ne connais pas les conditions
dans lesquelles ce drame est survenu je
ne sais pas si c'est un problème
d'octroi de permis je ne sais pas si
c'est un problème de vigilance et je ne
suis pas qualifié pour le commenter il
ya une enquête qui est en cours et je
pense que tant que toute la lumière
n'est pas faite tant que l' enquête n'a
pas abouti
la meilleure attitude c'est à la fois
d'être extrêmement solidaire mais je ne
sais pas si c'est le bon moment en
réalité avec la victime et de ne pas se
précipiter sur un drame pour en tirer
des conclusions ou en faire des
propositions à l'occasion de telle ou
telle calendrier politique
merci vincent au delà des drames y ait
un débat oui bien sûr certains donc
effectivement mais peut-être que cette
quantité des bugs propose d'interdire le
chlore week-end aussi rapidement sa
france est soumise d'ailleurs je ne
savais pas mais oui je pense que c'est
un débat qui ne peut pas être clos si
rapidement que cela dans une 2 dont elle
s'est construit c'est pas un débat très
récent non plus mais c'est vrai qu'il
est remis sur la table à chaque fois
qu'il ya ce type de drame il y en a
plutôt moins qu'avant d'ailleurs quand
on regarde l'histoire de la chasse mais
ils sont de moins en moins tolérées par
la société mais on va pas mourir cette
page avec vous messieurs bonsoir merci
beaucoup eric coquerel d'être avec nous
députés la france insoumise elle de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir jean françois
husson vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de meurthe et moselle et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances avait entre face à vous le le
ministre des comptes publics
chromé la caisse c'est une expression
qui a sorti ou en tout cas qu'à
réactiver valérie pécresse en tant que
candidate à la présidence de la
république elle accuse le gouvernement
d'avoir cramer la caisse d'avoir mal
utilisé les finances publiques
est ce que c'est votre cas et quelle est
votre interpellation à olivier du soft
vous commencez eric coquerel vous avez
deux questions vous dites qu'ils ont
cramé la caisse est ce que l'argent a
été mal utilisé à la première question
je dis non je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
cramé la caisse ils ont créé des
déficits qui était rendu nécessaire par
la crise du coc vide et je pense même
pour ma part et vous savez olivier
dussopt qu' on aurait pu faire plus les
américains ont fait beaucoup plus à peu
près 25% du pib quand nous on a mis 6 %
du pib
et on aurait pu faire là par contre
autrement c'est à dire qu'en réalité on
va continuer une politique qui est la
même politique de l'offre qu'on à
baisser l'impôt de production n'a
conduit à 2 à donner de l'argent aux
entreprises sans contrepartie nous on
est prêts dès l'âge aux entreprises avec
des contreparties les fléchant ce qui
fait qu'on a pas rempli record de 2,2 de
dividende l'an dernier 70 milliards de
dividendes qui ont été produits et
surtout moi la question que je pose
parce que bon ça c'est l'état des faits
aujourd'hui c'est que je crois que c'est
d'être que vick qui a une particularité
c'est qu'elle appartient à la banque 2 à
la banque de france et à l'est pas sur
les marchés sylla doute le csah sa
particularité sur décision la banque
centrale européenne moi je crois que il
ne faut pas lesté l'avenir avec cette
dette raisons pour lesquelles nous nous
proposons l'annuler soit par une
transformation des perpétuelles cemac
qui propose ça voyez c'est pas d une
simple au lieu de dans visage et une
politique d'austérité que nous promet et
onel macron s'il est réélu puisque ça a
été annoncé à l'as vence avec une baisse
de dépenses drastiques et nous on pense
qu'on doit justement permettre aux
générations à venir de ne pas partir
avec quelque chose qui a été due
principalement la question du coc vide
et ses conséquences alors vous permettez
grêce ils sont donne son point de vue et
après vous répondrai en deux
le point de vue il est un peu différent
si cramer la caisse oui mais je vais je
vais donné un premier chiffre le prénom
un public lorsqu'il était candidat en
2017 voulait réduire le déficit elle
ramener à 3% du pib il proposait donc
une économie de 60 milliards d'euros une
baisse de 5 milliard d'euros hors hors
dépenses d'urgence et de crise sanitaire
et vous le savez la dépense les dépenses
publiques ont augmenté pendant ce
quinquennat
de 60 milliards d'euros ce qui est
gênant c'est qui s'est trompé de
chiffres là où devait y avoir moins il a
mis plus et donc qu'est ce qu'il en
advient notre des publics et là on est
les derniers 1 en dettes publiques au
niveau européen en matière de dépanner
23e pardon on est quasiment dernier on
est en prélèvements obligatoires on est
27e sur 27 déficits publics 27e sur 27
et pour les dépenses publiques au niveau
de les céder on est les derniers donc on
est les bonnets d'âne si avec ça on
trouve beaucoup de motifs de
satisfaction je m'inquiète parce que
c'est aujourd'hui le moment de vérité on
est à un peu plus de 50 jours de
l'élection présidentielle
il est temps de dire aux français la
vérité de poser le débat les français
arbitreront en connaissance de cause
mais si je me suis trompé sur le moindre
chiffre je suis preneur vous savez très
bien que ce sont vos chiffres là donc
ils ne souffrent pas normalement de
discussion un budget de vision tant
mieux et la cram et la caisse rival je
te dis ton mieux
la caisse mais de la mal fait quant à
vous monsieur le sont il a mal utilisé
l'argent public qui n'a pas fait ce
qu'elle avait promis en termes de
rigueur et r2 de réponse non pas
différente mais à des questions
différentes et que je vais essayer dans
le complémentaire tout cas les réponses
d'abord eric coquerel a raison de dire
que vous avez toujours dit qu'on avait
bien fait de dépenser l'argent pas
forcément de dépenser comme cela vous
l'avez dit mais c'était nécessaire j'ai
deux points de désaccord premier point
de désaccord concerne la comparaison
vous faites avec les états unis nous
avons engagé beaucoup d'argent 140
milliards pour répondre à la crise plus
100 milliards d'euros du plan de relance
et le plan d'investissement qui c'est
une part moins importante que ce que les
états unis ont débloqué brutalement mais
avec une particularité c'est qu'en
france notre système de protection
sociale a joué son rôle d'amortisseur
très forte avec des minima sociaux mais
qui on a aussi augmenté qu'on craignait
c'est une bonne nouvelle avec une prise
en charge hospitalière et les états unis
dans les mesures d'urgence qui sont
mises en oeuvre que les états unis ont
mis en oeuvre il y avait des chèques
directement à destination des ménages
pour aider ceux qui n'avaient pas droit
à des allocations chômage il y avait
aussi des dz pour faire aux questions
médicales aux questions sociales fodé
système social comme celui qu'on avait
et s'explique largement la différence de
mobilisation faciale si je puis dire
deuxième point d accord c sur l'utilité
ce que nous avons fait en tout cas la
pertinence de ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui nous avons une économie qui
va bien nous avons une économie qui va
bien avec une croissance à 7 % avec des
emplois qui sont créés un taux de
chômage qui est neuf kbc et nous avons
et nous avons en partie remis n'est
possible en france me sens mais nous
avons dans les derniers chiffres du
chômage des bonnes nouvelles aussi le
chômage baisse et le nombre d'emplois à
temps partiel ou précaires diminue aussi
le chômage de longue durée diminue et je
m'agite diminue donc la situation est
plutôt bonne mais on y reviendra
d'accord il va me répondre à juger après
1800 sur sur l'économie va très bien je
sais ça c'est ce que nous dit le maire
en permanence et semblait pas très grave
c'est pas péjoratif doivent pas le
cheveu la croissance vous savez très
bien que on a augmenté de 7% mais par
rapport à une année où on avait baissé
de 8% donc si on se compare avec l'année
qu'au vide on va pouvoir des chiffres
mairie fiq de reprise de l'activité
économique puisqu'il faut regarder c'est
sûr long terme que ça c'est faux la
deuxième chose war dro chômage c'est que
les chiffres que vous annoncez là c'est
pareil la baisse du chômage vous la
voulez vous la calculer il a comparé par
rapport à la première année confinement
donc moi y avait eu une hausse du
chômage donc finalement il ya une baisse
de 4 2% si on regarde par rapport à 2 %
c'est moins avec lui c'est important
mais surtout les créations d'emplois que
vous vous mettez vous nous êtes
incapable de nous dire combien ça vaut
en équivalent temps plein or par exemple
au quatrième trimestre 2021 je termine
là dessus sur cent sept mille emplois
créés on estime que les deux tiers sont
en réalité des emplois d'intérim et un
intérim c'était deux semaines en moyenne
2021 donc moi j'aimerais avoir les
chiffres non et c'est important pour le
débat politique et cesser de verser
quand vous essayez d emplois qui sont
comptabilisés à partir d'une heure par
semaine comme les dom l'insee ça ne fait
pas forcément un emploi à 35 heures par
mois insight les chiffres et ceux de
l'insee et la note de l'insee sur quatre
avoue donné comme date des line 6 heures
par semaine vous avez un an laissez moi
répond d'accord avec cela la note de
l'insee sur la quatrième sur le 4e
trimestre précise que les emplois à
temps partiel les emplois précaires ont
diminué et que les emplois créés au
tiers de son 7000 on prend de meilleures
et gilles denis c est plutôt une bonne
chose sur le chiffre du chômage
nous étions à plus de 9% début du
quinquennat et nous sommes à 7,4 et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle non c'est les
118 mille jeunes qui sont emballés qui
sont des fans mais et et nous sommes
très heureux qu'ils sont en
apprentissage c'était notre objectif
mais ça c'est pas de messi et moi c'est
pas des emplois s'il en est c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais j'y répondrai à
jean-françois emploi et de la formation
je pense que la série n'est pas là la
consommation n'est pas là
on l'a retrouvé l'activité d'avant crise
et c'est l'essentiel à nos yeux parce
que c'est le signe de la reprise pour
répondre à jean françois husson je pense
que le président de la république a
démontré et et nous avec lui si vous le
permettez nous étions capables de tenir
des engagements c'est les trois années
avant la crise avec une diminution du
poids de la dépense publique avec une
diminution des prélèvements obligatoires
et aujourd'hui nous sommes à 43 6 % de
taux de prélèvements obligatoires alors
que nous étions à plus de 45% au début
du quinquennat tout à l'heure je disais
aux deux journalistes qui m'interrogeait
que nous avons effacé en termes de poids
des prélèvements obligatoires sur la
richesse produite et de chaque fils côte
2011 et 2013 donc nous avons diminuer
les prélèvements obligatoires et nous
avons engagé des dépenses qui sont
importantes et vous vous le savez on a
le débat à l'occasion de chaque projet
de loi de finances mais votre famille
politique me dit vous n'en fait pas
assez vous n'allez pas assez vite nous
avons deux réponses la première est que
nos stratégies radicalement différente
de celle de 2011 2012 à d'augmentation
d'impôts pas de croissance et ils vont
venir certainement pas les pas de
croissance étouffé
et puis il ya et puis et puis il ya une
deuxième il ya une deuxième réponse que
je fais systématiquement au groupe plr
au sénat et parfois même à celui de
l'assemblée c'est que lorsque
j'additionne les amendements qui seront
déposés par le groupe ait l'air à
l'occasion de chaque débat budgétaire
mais c'est pas un déficit de 5 % qu'on
aurait c'est 10 % parce qu'il ne se
passe pas une demi heure sans qu'il y
ait une proposition de dépenses d'accord
alors sur l'augmentation d'impôts ça
m'intéresse vous ne croyez pas aux
engagements qui sont bonnes aujourd'hui
de ne pas augmenter d'impôt bruno le
maire l'a effectivement pris l eau mais
plus que ça fait en dix ans la dette
entre la france et l'allemagne a
augmenté de 40 % 40 % il ya dix ans on
était quasiment au même niveau à touche
touche avec l'allemagne donc un moment
donné dans la solidarité européenne ça
va jouer c'est évident on peut pas être
le cancre de la classe et demande être
compensée comme le premier
quand vous écoutez et que vous voyez que
sur la zone euro
cet écart il est de 20 points je suis
désolé mais la france doit faire
attention à la dérive de sa dépense
publique c'est sa nuque en grain c'est
une forme de cancer et vous avez donc ça
de
partir du moment et dans la capacité de
réduire la dépense publique dans
l'incapacité le gouvernement a mis les
français dans la rue pour un certain
nombre de choses notamment dans la
réforme des retraites c'est à dire qu'
aucune mesure courageuse permettant de
rétablir les finances publiques n'a été
engagée et surtout à porter ses fruits
résultat demain je mets mon billet au
feu et je prends les paris évidemment
les français auront à payer la note avec
des augmentations de taxes et d'impôts
vous n'aurez pas le choix si vous êtes
élu
en attendant c'est pas sûr et c'est pas
apprécié comme suit 100 par
l'affirmative sur la perspective d'être
élu mais si j'ai après non non si si on
si on reprend l'argument qui est le sien
le moment où l'histoire pendant lequel
l'écart de dette honda france et
l'allemagne s'étaient plus croisés c'est
justement entre 2010 et 2013 parce qu'il
ya des politiques qui ont été mises en
oeuvre avec des augmentations d'impôts
sans qu'il y ait de croissance sans
qu'il y ait de possibilité de générer
des recettes pour pour l'avenir nous en
cette ligne cette ligne est gelée dit
tout à l'heure c'est que nous
considérons qu'on sort pas d'une crise
en augmentant les impôts et donc nous ne
voulons pas augmenter les impôts nous
n'augmenterons pas les impôts nous
l'avons démontré nous les avons baissé
nous avons baissé fortement et avec
cette double volonté vous allez de rang
de la compétitivité aux entreprises et
de rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux ménages
c'est ce que nous avons fait et et c'est
m une des réponses aussi à la crise
sociale
crazy mais si vous ne baissez pas la
dépense publique l'âme si vous augmentez
pas les impôts c'est moi c'est tout à
l'heure le président chanteur il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que je
réponde à des questions d'actualité de
votre groupe qui me demandent de
dépenser toujours plus donc non non
surtout de me connaissez
mais je connais votre position inverse
mais je connais aussi celle de votre
groupe et ça n'est jamais assez par
contre monsieur coquerel le disait vous
allez baisser la dépense publique s'agit
pas de sagy pas de l'abaisser hills mais
j'avais annoncé s'agit de limiter son
augmentation non entre deux entre 2017
et 2020 nous avons tenu les 3 % et nous
sommes revenus en hausse de 3% sans
jamais baisser la dénonce vous avez
annoncé dans le grand est soulevée du
sol vous avez annoncé vous étiez en face
de moi avec bruno le maire vous avez
annoncé pour les cinq ans à venir 01 46
% d'augmentation ce qui fait que par
rapport à la population et l'appelation
en réalité vous avez 10 et relu ce que
vous l'avez jamais fait puisque pour
l'instant c'est à peu près 1 %
d'augmentation en moyenne 600 donc vous
avez la d6 drastiquement vous l'assumez
ça c'est made in design et une maîtrise
a remarqué que nous épate c'est vrai
vous vous dites que pendant cinq ans y
compris avec une loi organique qui va
encadrer tout ça il s'agit de dirt 2 de
repartir vers les rails des 3% des grecs
c'est ce qui vous a à peu près la même
logique en fait ils république à bout
d'ici si les républicains vous dise vous
fait pas assez vous avez finalement vous
allez augmenter les impôts moi je vous
dis je pense que si dans les cinq ans à
venir on continue à baisser la dépense
publique mais alors on a des problèmes
d'éducation en épreuve de santé on a des
problèmes à peu près dans tout l'est
dans tous les pays y compris en termes
de transition écologique on a besoin de
l'argent
même problème que celui de que celle de
la france alors et nation que la grêle
avec un système de santé en déperdition
vouliez en train d'être agréé et c'est
aussi des injustices et surtout des
inégalités c'est fondamental pour les
prix alors c'est vrai cinéma sur la
dette et on ne peut pas même les jeunes
ont bien su monique on verra pour
l'instant il n'a pas encore
il ne s'est pas encore imposé mais
effectivement c'est une question
cruciale que la dette aussi interpellé
vous me direz tout à l'heure la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des plus pauvres
alors qu' il ya des supers profits en
quelques instants vous recevrez
classieuse son rectangle c'est de parler
de l'écologie en quelques instants c'est
simple 86 les flux grandes fortunes l'an
dernier ont augmenté de 86% 236
milliards et la danse et surtout les
revenus capital 70 milliards dividende
d'un autre côté 10 millions de pauvres
dans ce pays et les pauvres sont plus en
plus pauvres les salaires baisse par
rapport à l'inflation de manière
générale on nagel d'indicé des
fonctionnaires qui continuent et on a un
pouvoir d'achat réel ya une élection est
une alternative économique qui montrent
que depuis dix ans le pouvoir d'achat a
quasiment stagné alors que les plus
riches n'a pas de question qu'elle est à
côté finat eu d'un côté c'est dû à quoi
des cadeaux fiscaux importants
entreprises particuliers aides aux
entreprises sans contrepartie qui sont
pérennes et de l'autre côté les mesures
vous allez sûrement de parler pourvoir
d'achat qui elles sont ponctuels et donc
ma question c'est eux on va continuer
jusqu où comme ça à mettre les revenues
d'un côté et de manière la plus
inégalitaire possible au détriment des
salaires et au détriment de la
consommation populaire le revenu des 20%
de ménages pensent et les moins
favorisés nous les plus défavorisés a
augmenté de 4% par an c'est beaucoup
plus que tout le reste n'est pas moi
qu'il dit céline cje désolé balle
insights à l'institut un honneur dont il
ya une augmentation du revenu des
ménages les plus fragiles qui en
pourcentage est plus forte que pour tout
le reste et c'est très bien et ça
s'explique à la fois par la baisse des
cotisations ça s'explique par la
revalorisation des minima sociaux vous
allez me dire ce n'est pas assez j'en
suis absolument convaincu mais nous
sommes les premiers à avoir augmenté le
minimum vieillesse 200 euros et ogre
armand augmenter l'allocation des dépôts
les personnes handicapées 200 euros par
mois ça n'avait jamais été fait nous
sommes aussi les premiers à voir
augmenter la prime d'activité au niveau
du smic aussi fortement donc vous pouvez
me dire que ce n'est pas assez je vous
dise c'est faux je vous dis et je vous
dis que le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
les plus fragiles a augmenté de 4% soit
plus rapidement que le reste est une île
sans épée soit ce sont les chiffres de
l'insee ce sont les chiffres qui
ressortent de leur vie n'est pas
d'accord si vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur
les chiffres n'ont pas ce que l'on fait
sans parler de la réalité si on met tout
ça s'il arrêtait les français après les
10 millions de pauvres ils sont bien
réels dans ce pays en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté s'est hissée absolument
historiques et par contre les chiffres
que je faisais des augmentations de la
richesse qu'ils sont historiques aussi
ce qui fait qu'on a le quinquennal qui
suit inégale de la vème république
comparaison du point le plus bas de la
robe
blanche c'est un carton rouge que je
voudrais adresser au gouvernement et que
vous représentez sur le finalement les
chèques qui est le vôtre sur l'enjeu
écologique vous avez débuté le
quinquennat avec la volonté d'augmenter
avec un raidissement très fort la taxe
carbone vous avez envoyé les gilet jaune
avec tout le cortège de violence mais
aussi pour certains de souffrance de
certaines populations qui se sont
exprimés vous êtes parti au début de ce
quinquennat en tournant en vous mettant
les pas dans ceux de la majorité
précédente c'était la fin du nucléaire
en fermer fessenheim et puis
crise de l'énergie en ce moment où vous
faites la politique de l'autruche on
bloque temporairement en baisse des
taxes et on dit tout ça sera payé à
partir du mois de juin 2022 et en 2023
ça n'est pas responsable ça n'est pas
raisonnable et surtout il n'y a pas de
cap alors il n'y a pas de cap je le
comprend quatre ministres quatre
ministres pour s'occuper de l'écologie
en cinq ans il ya eu un casting on a
commencé par nicolas hulot et puis c'est
parti finalement un peu dans toutes les
directions quel dommage alors que
l'enjeu climatique le défi énergétique
alors on a aujourd'hui des banques mais
parce qu'on n'aura pas des vraies
réponses fortes à apporter comment
expliquez vous cet échec de votre
gouvernement pendant ces cinq ans
en matière d'écologie ce gouvernement
c'est une augmentation du budget du
ministère de la transition écologique
d'un milliard par an ça produit
aujourd'hui sanaryens cinq ans de
relance qui permet de mobiliser 35
milliards d'euros avec des objectifs qui
sont atteints et nous ajoutons à cela
les 15 milliards d'euros pour lutter
contre la hausse des prix suivie par les
français dans le cas d'une crise
énergétique
des peignées la situation comme un échec
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je ne
partage pas et je pense que les
dernières annonces du président de la
république concilier à la fois
l'ambition industrielle que celui là le
principe et la nécessité d'avoir un
modèle nucléaire que j'assume et que je
partage pour passer d économie d énergie
carbone et fossiles à des énergies
renouvelables et il ya une période de
transition qui nécessite le nucléaire et
j'ai toujours considéré ce rapatriation
en extraire les eps et une énergie utile
parce que cette énergie et est
certainement la moins polluante
aujourd'hui même si je garde en tête les
questions vaudra les à fessenheim il
faudra la fessenheim et voir les
alsaciens dans les yeux pour pouvoir
discuter l'association de fessenheim
avec la filière nucléaire ici et je
connais à distance et par les fonctions
qui sont les miennes la situation de
fessenheim y compris sur
l'accompagnement que l'état apporte il a
encore des sujets qui sont en cours vous
le savez parfaitement et sur lesquels le
gouvernement est mobilisé voilà c'est le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup lâchez-nous
la dette c'est le titre de votre livre
tout est en effet la dette abyssale qui
a été creusée dites-vous par nécessité
et finalement heureuse elle est moins
important et c'est une bonne nouvelle
pardon ça ne dépendra pas que de
monsieur du choc dépendra ben ça
dépendra du choix qui va être fait mais
on a on est tenu par un engagement
européen on ne peut pas être solidaire
selon la bonne volonté de chacun ont
fait remarquer que la bce a décidé
unilatéralement de rompre avec les
tripes t on prétend directement aux
états oui on peut le c'est juste
circonstance exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles merci beaucoup en tout
cas à tous les deux messieurs les
parlementaires jean françois husson eric
coquerel d'avoir accepté de débattre
avec olivier dussopt merci beaucoup
c'est tout sauf d'avoir été notre invité
une émission qui a été marqué au début
par la tente des déclarations de
vladimir poutine on rappelle un conseil
exceptionnel de défense ce soit pour
tirer toutes les conséquences de ce que
le maître du kremlin aura annoncé il est
en ce moment en train de parler à la
télévision publique russe bonne soirée
pas démission lundi prochain pas de
décision publique on se retrouve le 7
février à 19h30 merci de nous avoir
suivis bonne soirée 7 mars le 7 mars et
oui comme le temps passe le 7 mars merci
à vous merci monsieur leçons et monsieur
coquerel bonne soirée sur s&p et public
sénat
[Musique]